tres exalcaldes dos senadores y una sola
misión arrancarle votos a una izquierda
en ascenso equipo por colombia es una
alianza que representa a los políticos
de derecha y centroderecha de antaño sus
caras visibles son viejos conocidos en
la política nacional y regional
enrique peñalosa ha sido dos veces
alcalde de la capital bogotá tras
navegar por varias colectividades hoy
representa al partido de la u
federico gutiérrez es ingeniero civil
cercano al expresidente álvaro uribe y
ex alcalde de medellín la segunda ciudad
del país si algo unió a los integrantes
de esta coalición es presentarse como
una alternativa a la izquierda a la que
señalan de promover una deriva hacia un
sistema socialista y antidemocrático
afín al de venezuela pero aquí hay que
entender cuáles son los dos modelos es
un modelo de quienes quieren destruir
empresas y otro que es el nuestro donde
queremos cuidar la empresa y que haya
más empleo otro modelo que lo que quiere
es expropiar y nosotros lo que queremos
es que por el contrario el campesino
tenga el título de su tierra la pueda
explotar y que protejamos también la
inversión privada nacional hacemos la
tercera carta es alejandro char nacido
de una prominente casta empresarial que
en la costa caribe controla desde el
comercio hasta el fútbol fue dos veces
alcalde de barranquilla considerada la
nueva cuna del desarrollo industrial su
campaña ha estado empañada por
acusaciones de corrupción por parte de
la ex congresista y de merlano condenada
por compra de votos y que se refugió en
venezuela huyendo de la justicia
colombiana a los ex alcaldes los
acompañan dos senadores el conservador
david barguil miembro de las comisiones
económicas del congreso y hay de
lizarazo del partido mira una
colectividad cristiana cuyos votos han
sido claves para la derecha en
elecciones anteriores
equipo por colombia dice ser la apuesta
de centroderecha pero en esta alianza no
figura del derechista centro democrático
el partido gobernante esta colectividad
decidió postular a su propio candidato
para la primera fase de la contienda el
ex ministro de hacienda óscar iván
zuluaga hará un segundo intento por
llegar al palacio de nariño el recorrido
el país y les puedo decir que ese cambio
que piden los colombianos no es hacia la
izquierda es hacia arriba
una derecha fragmentada buscará
consolidar dos décadas de hegemonía y de
paso hacerle frente a una izquierda que
en 2018 por primera vez en la historia
logró escalar a una segunda ronda
presidencial y cuyo representante
gustavo petro encabeza las encuestas